hello everyone and welcome to the fifth
leg of the Grantchester it's the single
Cup and here we have young opponent with
the white pieces against Vishwanathan
Anand
now the pairings here will be the same
as in Zagreb only with the colors
reversed so whoever got the black pieces
seen in Zagreb will have the white
pieces here and the belt the players
will be battling it out for the prize
fund is three hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars within ninety thousand
dollars for first place which is a lot
more than for example when Joe Bhuvana
won the Abu Dhabi Masters he only won
thirteen thousand dollars for first
place
Alba okay this is a much bigger
tournament and they have Rex Sinquefield
sponsoring them the time limit is a
hundred and thirty minutes per player
and they will have a 30-second delay
starting from one now constant just had
a pretty bad event in the st. Luis rapid
in blitz tournament but this is
classical chess and a lot of you say
that why I never say what the time
format is in the video but the time
former will always be in the description
if I don't mention it and I will always
mention the time format at the start of
the video but here cross and start
starts which is I believe 2882 rating or
28 yeah I think it's 2882 and or maybe
2880 something but he will be now trying
to reach 2900 for the first time ever in
classical chess but he has to really
perform spectacularly to achieve such a
to break the threshold but okay getting
back to the game Jana Papa she with the
white pieces opens with c4 so the
English is on the board we have E 5 and
Knight to c3 the reversed Sicilian
variation of the English with Bishop to
b4 Knight to d5 now pushing the bishop
back bishop back to e7 and here Knight
to f3 with d6 by Anand and the now comes
d4 and here are a lot of moves have been
tried efore has been played here c6 has
been played here pawn captures here in
96 has been played in 97 has been played
but the move Anand plays Knight to f6 is
a new move and it's very interesting
already as a move 6 we have a completely
new game with Knight back to sea 3 by
Neto and now II capture some d4 Knight
capture some d4 and now d5 getting rid
of the well maybe a back respond in the
future
why not just push it right away Bishop
to f4 by nepo and now comes castles and
here III by nipple nice the b5 seems
like you're creating some threats here
against the c7 phone but black can just
play a six and if you capture on c7 you
actually lose material there should be
four check if you don't want to lose the
Queen you have to block with the bishop
but then the knight and c7 is unguarded
so you just capture and then pick up the
piece so not possible with III by nipple
and now on our place a six preventing
any knight B 5 action in the future
Knight back to f3 and now c6
strengthened in the center net portrays
once we have C captures Knight captures
Knight captures Queen captures and here
nay portraits Queens we have Queen
captures C captures and finally a
queenside castle attacking the pawn here
now as under achieved a new position
here it is likely that he has this all
analyzed and the d5 pawn is under attack
now if you defend it with the Bishop to
e6 you're gonna get Knight d5 the bishop
will be under attack and in a position
like this you do want to keep the bishop
pair so on and defends it with Knight to
c6 and now if you capture the pawn now
you get Bishop to e6 where you have to
move the rook then come as a bishop
characters on a2 and the White King will
be under a lot of pressure here the
bishop can come to f6 and it's not gonna
be easy defending stone epic hero tries
Bishop to g5 he wants to trade bishops
and then maybe have his night on g5
already guarding the e6 square island
pushes it back with f6 Bishop to f4 and
only now Bishop to e6 defending it now
that his
f6 pawn defense from any infiltration of
the night also the knight from c6 guards
d4 with King Tubby 1 you know that Anand
is developing the roof to c8 so why not
just get rid of the King right away
rook a c8 and now a 3 taking away the be
4 square from Allan's pieces with rook F
to d8 now developing the the last rook
and here Bishop to d3
you might wanna it's usually the case
where we want to blockade the isolated
pawn and then attack it later but here
we don't have anything to block hit it
with if Knight here then
black can just capture it and if rookery
captures the rook is not a good
blockading piece in in most cases so
here Bishop to d3 nipple continues
development and now Bishop to c5 with
King rook hd1 again developing the the
last rook and king f7 on and now starts
to bring the King into the game with
Bishop to g3 and now Bishop back to b6
now opening up the C file for the rook
and here comes a bush of the c2 nepo
does the same with h5 preparing g5 and
h4 and h3 making room for the bishop on
h2 if needed and now tonight the e7 on
and now prepares not that might do a 5
to harass the bishop and well whoever
wins the bishop error here should have
the advantage with Bishop to b3 here
neppo is trying to get on it to go for
the bishop for example if Knight to f5
here Bishop f4 and if g5 now here nipple
head Bishop captures and g5 plans to
give up the piece for three pawns after
pawn captures Knight captures with check
King moves wherever king of 16 b7 now
you capture and after King captures now
he push me for as the d5 pawn is pinned
and now after the knight moves Knight d6
you're gonna capture here you you have
three points for the piece most likely
we're gonna grab more pawns and on and
the doesn't like this so first and
prepares night at five he plays g5 now
Bishop therefore will no longer be
possible but first we have 8 4 again
Knight f5 can now be met with H garrison
g5 and then the g5 Square will once
again be weak so here Allen just pushes
g4 we have night study for and now on
and decides to give up the dark square
Bishop will but should capture some d4
rook captures on d4 and now Knight to c6
pushing the rule back
we've looked back a rook to f4 now seems
like an odd place to put the rope but if
it works you know black it doesn't
really seem to have a way of attacking
it and now d4 on the trades the other
bishop as well with Bishop captures King
captures and now e capture son d4
temporarily sacrificing a pawn you can
go here because you have to keep an eye
on df6 pawn so uh none goes back King to
f7
and now you could try to defend it but
defending it gives black a lot of
activity for example if Rudy one then
rook e97
preparing to harass the brook and also
rook c-4 is coming where you will attack
the pawn once again and now after f3
Knight d5 you put back the rook rook e4
and G captures on f3 now G captures rook
g8 this is what black would play if
white tries to defend the pawn and now
black rooks are really just you know a
powerhouse and the white rooks are stuck
guarding the d4 pawn so nipple doesn't
enjoy this he tries to give back the
pawn he plays f3 and ok we have G
captures rook captures and mountain
Knight captures on d4 I'm grabbing back
at the pawn nipple goes rook to at 4 and
we have nice to e 6 back attacking the
rook rook back to f3 and now again
Knight the d4 will rue cler 4 and here
net boy saying okay if you wanna draw
you can go for a threefold repetition
with Knights to e6 but here on and says
no way nice to be three he says no draw
on and says that his position is better
and that he will continue playing this
game because he has a night against the
bishop and usually a bishop will be
better if it's if you know if a game is
being played on both sides of the board
but Anand supports are on light squares
so he doesn't have to worry about the
bishop all that much and well yeah he
says that he's the only one who can push
for more than a draw in this position
with Bishop to f2 by nepo and now rook
the c-4 a very nice idea where Allen
finds a way to get rid of a pair of
rooks so here
rook captures night D to check with King
to c2 and now Knight picks up the rook
so on and says his Knight is better than
the bishop here and he would like to
exchange rooks we have roopd to
preventing rugby to check and now comes
the knight back to e5 with Bishop to e 1
& 2 now comes King to e6 further
improving the position and now wants to
get King at 5 king g4 and go after the G
to pawn with a 4 by nepo rook to d6 now
and now g3 with King to f5 now the G 4
square is available for the king
have to check King g4 and now rook the
f4 check with King to h3 and here allons
King would be well in somewhat of a
danger if for example nepo had a night
against a bishop but since he's on a
light square he doesn't have all that
much to worry about and Knepper will
have to keep an eye on the g3 pawn for a
very long time and here
rook f5 with an attack against the h5 1
which has been Nepos best move he he
went looked to f1 and he loud rook c6
check with King Tubby one now and now
Luke back to e six now comes rook to 5
so the idea is the same only he wasted
some time but now he gets nice to g6 and
he asks well do you want to grab a pawn
and then I win your piece of course he
doesn't want that with bishop to have to
and now kink the g4 defending the pawn
rook back to d5 and now Knights thief
I've again we've roped a d4 check King
to h3 and now look back to d5 and here
look to East 7 now just keeping an eye
on all the points here he wants to play
rook h7 the roof from h7 will be keeping
an eye on the b7 point and on the h5
phone so kink the c2 trying to get the
King into the game if if rook d6
attacking the pawn Knight g4 just
defends it while attacking the bishop
so King c2 we have Knight to g4
attacking the bishop and the bishop back
to be 6 so now you have to keep leave
the be g3 pond undefended but your h5
point is also undefended so first rook
to h7 and now rook to d3 both players
now defend their pawns knights the e5
trying to get the rook away from the
defense of the g3 pawn rook the b3 and
now comes Luke the d7
with Bishop be back to III and now
Knight to f3 now you are ready to
capture the pawn as well white doesn't
really have all that all that many
discoveries we have looked to be six and
now King characters on g3 with rook
captures on f6 and now Knight captures
on h4 on and wins the pawn and now on
and just wants to get rid of the night
and start pushing his passport with b4
by nepo and now comes Knight to G to the
point is now ready to be
with Bishop to e7 preparing Bishop to be
a check
and now h4 with King to c3 and now h3 at
preparing h2 and h1 Queen
so Bishop to be a check by nepo King to
g4 and now rook to g6 check with Tim to
h5 and now look back to g8
we have nights to e3 going for Knight to
g4 so d h2 push will be protected by the
night we have roof to g3
not with a double attack and now Knight
d5 check first with King back to B 3 and
now King to h4 defending the pawn row
back to g8 and mountain Knight to f6
again attacking the rook if you go
ricochet to check rook h7 it's not a
problem
Sofia looked at g6 by neppo attacking
the knight and now Knight to g4 we have
ripped the g8 and now you know you can
push up on right away because 88 checked
and both the rook and the bishop attack
the pawn so rook to h7 first you have to
put a rogue behind a passed pawn and now
nepos starts bringing the king
interrogating Kings before with h2 and
could prepare this push a bit more but
he's very low on the clock and he
decided that he's ready to to win nepos
bishop with h2 Bishop captures on h2
Knight captures on h2 and now b5 nipple
wants to trade off all the pawns and
then in trend and hold a draw with rook
against the rook and Knight with Knight
to g4 by Anand and now rook to e8 with a
cactus the story not a capture some b5
we have King captures on b5 and now
comes Knight to f6
so if nipple can get rid of this point
it will be very good for him with a 5
Knight to d5 and now rook to a7 and here
Anand plays came to g5 so he has to keep
this pawn protected and bring his skin
closer so he can start with winning the
a 5 point and then trying to put four
more and here the problem is you cannot
push a6 if you push a 6 to trade off the
the last pawn you get a nice e7 check
and after King b6 you get B captures on
a6 and the point is not a nicely
protected by the night if you capture
black just captures rook and if you
decide to win a piece then
the problem is you can never catch up to
to the ape on the a pond is faster and
you get a queen here after king g5
nipple had to play King to c5 but he
played a different move
he played King to c4 and here it's well
it just doesn't work so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning move for Anand in this position
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
Punisher of blunders by a white and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show here and played b5 check and it was
in this position that nipple resigned
the game why did he resign well of
course you all saw it after King after
Sun d5 you win a night but then you get
the rook captures on a7 the rook is now
undefended and now of course it's a
completely winning endgame on the other
hand if you play a captures on b5 you
get rid of check while defending your
rook it seems like white defense but the
your problem is night to capture some B
sex with check rook is once again
undefended and after king b5 you're
gonna capture the rook captures you're
gonna move the rook and now of course
the rook and King and game against King
is completely winning as well
after this b5 move nipple resigns and
Anand wins the first game of the
tournament and Anand is the only Anand
is the only player who won his game in
round one of the Sinquefield Cup which
is a bit different in zagreb I think
there were four or even five decisive
games in round one or maybe three but
definitely more than one yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
Napo versus Anand around one of the
single Cup I would like to thank Jeff
graves and Marco fights for a conclusion
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video so you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing this Infeld Cup continue in
the Capablanca saga and of course
checking up in your suggestions thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent receiver Sunday and if you use
this cord do join to join our discord
server the link will be in the
description below see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day